on est bien que deux choses et mon amie
la rose me l'a dit ce matin
à new moore je suis
baptisée une rente ai je me suis épanoui
bonjour et bienvenue dans notre nouvel
épisode 10 petite amie la semaine
dernière était placée sous le signe de
la vigueur et de l'énergie avec une
partie de basket tout en bonne humeur
cette semaine nous vous invitons à
découvrir un univers calme et relaxant
la salle ce noël
bienvenue dans la salle selon hélène ça
en fait un concept qui est inventé par
deux hollandais c'est la contraction de
deux mots chenu flaine et 2 hélène roche
me solène veut dire sentir renifler et 2
hélène somme de lévis ça montre bien les
deux axes en fait de cette salle soit un
axe plutôt orientée vers la découverte
sensorielle puisqu'ils et leçons souris
moteur stimulation exploration nation
guidé par un accompagnateur ou le
deuxième axe qui est plutôt le repos la
détente
on avait des jeunes qui sont dorment
dans cette pièce on utilise par exemple
pour la résolution de conflits lorsqu'on
sent qu'un jeune devient énervé qui
l'excité on peut l'emmener ici donc avec
une relation duelle on le différents
ateliers donc en le cam la salle est
très content de la présence de
l'obscurité ça lui permet de se poser un
peu de se recentrer sur lui même et en
général 2 d'éviter le conflit ou bien
vraiment la crise qui a précédé
plusieurs haqqani pour mieux comprendre
le mieux c'est encore de tester ces
ateliers
maintenant que tout le monde en sait un
peu plus sur ce concept snoezelen
partons à la découverte des ateliers en
commençant par les bulles de lumière et
la fibre optique
voici les premiers ateliers basés comme
vous le constatez sur la vue ou que
celui-ci est à tu vas au avec des bulles
ça a un côté très très apaisant normand
tout est fait dans une ville dans
l'obscurité ses côtés très apaisant la
lumière change de couleur ils doivent
juste à côté on a des défis lumineux qui
sur le même principe change de couleur
c'est ils sont tous recouverts de
caoutchouc ou vais voir les jeunes
autistes qu'il est mort debout autres il
ya aucun souci ce que ya pas de fils
électriques vraiment dedans c'est bien
protégé c'est conçu pour
oh
m
et toute la salle et quand même
recouverte de mousse ou vous remarqué
que tout ce qui est en deux autres est
recouvert de façon à protéger le but
c'est vraiment de permettre aux jeunes
de découvrir 60 soit réellement soit de
s'apaiser mais dans un cadre très
sécurisant et protégés
passons maintenant au second atelier
donc c'est un atelier qui est basée à la
fois sur la lumière et le son il réagit
comme pu le voir aux différents sons
avec une fréquence plus ou moins
importantes verrez le nombre de bars
lumineuse augmente et donc ça permet aux
jeunes déjà deux ne joue avec la lumière
et pour tous les jeunes déficients
auditifs de prendre une certaine
conscience de leurs sons et de
différentes tonalités qui peuvent
émettre
les jeunes vont maintenant tester goyi
balançoire
donc c'est un lit chine ce qui est
suspendu il sert à s'allonger donc nous
il n'y a absolument rien qui retient en
cela par le crochet donc que certains
jeunes mettre les pieds à terre et se
balancent parce qu'au niveau de la
sensation que ce alors qu au kursaal et
s'appelle se détendre de se relaxer
c'est plutôt orienté donc détente et
relaxation que découverte sensorielle
comme outil bien que l'accompagnateur en
fonction de ce qu'ils recherchent
puissent quand même joué dessus
c'est comme en ligne
passons maintenant aux matelas à eau
donc c'est un matelas haut vous pouvez
constater avec des baffes qui sont
positionnées juste dessous moi la
musique me soit sortir dans toute la
pièce soit uniquement sur les baffes sur
les cas je suis assis donc généralement
les jeunes sont allongés dessus et là il
se laisse plus ou moins emporter par la
musique ou parce qu'ils sont déficients
auditifs c'est juste un jeu de
vibrations régulière ou non en fonction
la musique on joue sous les tempo par
exemple et donc c'est très relaxant et
certains finissent même par s'endormir
dessus tellement c'est agréable
après l'eau découvrant le sol
sensorielles en compagnie d'adam lind
donc c'est un atelier basé sur le sens
du toucher les jeunes marchent dessus
hersant différentes sensations qui sont
dues aux différentes textures des dalles
que l'on peut modifier aussi donc le but
en général s'est défait un marché
gourmand débat qu'est ce qu'ils
ressentent qu'est ce qui est agréable
qu'est ce que ça leur fait nous avons
une exploration du sens du toucher
au-delà de l'aspect ludique le concept
snow allen est très utile tant du point
de vue sensorielle que psychologique
c'est ce que nous explique alexis
c'est la fin de cette session snow
hélène les jeunes ont utilisé les
ateliers sensoriels pour se détendre
maintenant des prêts pour les répéter
après cette séance tout en douceur et en
surprises nous vous donnons rendez vous
la semaine prochaine pour faire un point
sur l'avancée des répétitions
compagnie de toute la troupe à très
bientôt
on